what's balen scroll up to now just how
powerful is Ezra and most importantly
what the heck is Zeb these are Big
questions and ahsoka's latest episode
holds the answers episode 7 of Ahsoka
finally reunites Ahsoka Tano with Sabine
Wren and Ezra Bridger on viridia but the
circumstances are far from ideal the
Jedi's quest to assess their allies in
their fight against baleen's skull and
shinharti has allowed Grand Amaral
thrawn to escape the planet and return
to the known Galaxy clearly our heroes
are facing an uphill battle the latest
installment of the Disney plus series
also includes some telling moments of
dialogue adding more depth to certain
characters and addressing the fates of
others so what might you have missed a
long time ago
in a galaxy far far away
Ahsoka reunites most of the surviving
members of the ghost crew from Star Wars
Rebels but the current whereabouts of
Zeb was until now a mystery however this
question is answered when a conversation
between Sabine Wren and Ezra Bridger
reveals that he's currently training the
next generation of Fighters for the new
Republic
New Republic zeb's training recruits and
Harris commanding Fleet
while there are many Star Wars fans out
there who want to see him join up with
his old comrades again it's good to know
that he's keeping busy of course zeb's
current role in the galaxy far far away
was hinted out in the Mandalorian as he
makes an appearance and that show's
third season well this is basically a
throwaway scene in the grand scheme of
things it suggests that Zeb will have a
bigger role to play in Disney Plus's
live-action Star Wars output in the near
future with a war between the New
Republic and Grand Amaral thrawn
seemingly on the horizon Ahsoka and the
Gang will need all of the Allies they
can find zeb's piloting and combat
skills will no doubt be extremely useful
to their mission fans will agree of
course that zeb's comeback can't come
soon enough and there's Balin SCAR
balein or Elise Dave filoni is clearly a
scholar of Earthling history that's
ahsoka's first season has seen him
repeatedly reference quotes from real
life historical figures for example
episode 4 sees in Bayer march to Pablo
Picasso when he proclaims that
one Must Destroy in order to create
this quotes essentially paraphrases the
greatest Mantra that every Act of
Creation begins with an act of
Destruction and it really makes you
wonder what baylen's grand plan is
really about episode 7 meanwhile sees
Balin directly quotes King Louis XIV
when he tells shinharti that
in patience for victory
will guarantee defeat given that the
17th century French monarch enjoyed a
72-year Reign on the throne it's safe to
say that he learned a thing or two about
playing the long game this is wise
advice to give to an ambitious Warrior
who craves power in her own right and
this says a lot about balin's mindset
heading into the upcoming War but what
do these historical quotes mean for the
former Jedi for one thing they clearly
show that he's willing to be patient
before initiating a secret master plan
we already know that Balin wants Ron to
start a war presumably so he can rebuild
the Galaxy From the Ashes afterward
however his words to Shin in episode 7
highlight the fact he doesn't expect
change to happen overnight and that is
probably harboring ulterior motives back
on the side of the Angels ahsoka's
seventh episode displays Ezra Bridges
new status as a full-on force ninja one
who doesn't need lightsabers or blasters
to help him win a fight in the fight
against shin and her minions he tells
Sabine now
forces my Ally
that's all I need after this he defeats
their foes using both the force and some
good old-fashioned brawling what's more
Ezra manages to block one of Shin's
lightsaber attacks with his mind which
is a rare accomplishment even for the
most skilled force wielders that said
Ezra isn't the first person to pull it
off Darth Vader does the same to Reaver
in Obi-Wan Kenobi when she tries to
attack him from behind with her own
lightsaber kylo Ren and Rey also
mastered a trek in the rise of Skywalker
this moment essentially confirms that
Ezra has mastered the ways of the force
and that is nearly as formidable as some
of the most powerful beings in the
galaxy